hello good morning we begin with
breaking news convicted murderer levi
bellfield has admitted in a letter to
the murders of mother and daughter lynn
and megan russell 26 years ago
in what's being described as a full and
frank confession mr bellfield is
currently serving a life sentence for
the murder of school girl millie dowler
and two other women well our crime
correspondent martin bronze joins me now
so martin how significant then is this
letter how does it change things as it
stands
it's a huge development
if
like many of us who covered
both michael stone's trials if you
believe that he probably wasn't the
killer
then levi bellfield is a very good
candidate and has long
been a suspect um
he knew the area
the nature of the attacks on
uh the russells um fits a pattern of uh
his other attacks bear in mind that he
is a serial killer he's serving life
for three murders and other attacks um
during which he used a hammer and what's
always struck me is that he bore or
bears a remarkable
resemblance to the photo fit of a
suspect that was put out 26 years ago
after the russell's murder now i've
spoken this morning to michael stone's
solicitor paul bacon who for 15 years
has been trying to prove michael stone's
innocence
he says
firstly he has this alleged confession
from belfield uh he believes it's
genuine uh he won't say uh how he came
by it um but he he describes it as a
full and frank confession and he really
believes that if the police
now go and interview bellfield
about what he's written in this
statement then mr bacon believes that
bellfield will admit um to the killings
michael stone was twice uh convicted
and has always denied killing the
russells now
there's some chilling details in
this statement that bellfield's alleged
to have
written and um i think the feeling is
that some of those details are the kind
of details that would only be known to
the killer um this is something of what
bellfield has written in this statement
i was wearing bright yellow marigold
washing up gloves and holding a hammer
in my right hand
in my car i had a screwdriver a lock
knife a hammer yellow marigold gloves
and a very long black boot lace my first
intention was to just attack lynn but i
quickly changed my mind due to the
screams and was worried she would fight
back given the children were with her
now i recall from
michael stone's
two trials he was convicted then the
conviction was crossed and then he was
reconvicted the evidence was always
very very thin there was no forensic
evidence for a start
and in court stone who was a heroin um
user or addict um struck a pretty
pitiful
character i'm not even i can't even
remember whether he actually gave
evidence in his own defense he might not
have done
but the kind of evidence that the
prosecution put forward was that they
found for instance a shoelace
with knots in it
and the prosecution case went a bit like
this well
michael stone is a heroin user heroin
users use shoelaces with knots in to tie
around their arms to give them a vein to
inject into
so that means that that's powerful
evidence against michael stone it was
really much along those kind of lines
what's happening now is paul bacon will
send this statement to the police but
also to the criminal cases review
commission
which is already considering an
application from michael stone stone is
61 he's appealed to the ccrc
uh once before but had his
his application rejected the ccrc is now
considering the second one so this
um you'd have thought on the face of it
will be more powerful evidence uh in
michael stone's um defense
but crucially paul bacon michael stone's
solicitor really believes he told me
that if the police were now to interview
bellfield
mr bacon feels that he will finally
admit to the russell murders